hello I was just reading Twitter and
someone asked me just seen where would
your tech Tuesdays and you're cooking
Thursday videos that ah I didn't make
them I didn't do it I didn't make one so
I thought I would just make a nice
little random video today talking about
whatever happens to come to mind and
what actually is coming to mind right
now
is I have been on the hunt for two pairs
of glasses that I got I'm currently
wearing a pair of glasses that I
actually lost these glasses two years
ago and I just recently found them but
now that I went back to try to find the
glasses that I actually want to wear the
new ones that I had got to replace these
ones I can't find them
hello dog can you maybe help me find my
glasses
I can't give me some sniffs do you have
an inch oh I also would like to discuss
how do you stop being a hoarder I don't
think I'm necessarily hoard but I'm I am
a messy person like if let's just look
at my desk right now we've got a bag of
pretzels I've got a can of yerba Monti
over here and there's just a bunch of
stuff everywhere and I just find myself
in in quite the disarray this is where I
think the glasses are I think that it
might be somewhere in here this is my
Lego collection that I have not managed
to reset up oh snap this my friends is
the GoPro dog harness whole matting you
don't even know what you're in for
it's not in here Maddy burned my glasses
where are they
I'm actually trying to think where they
could be because I really just don't
have any idea if I actually find these
glasses while I'm making this video it's
gonna be the most revolutionary video of
all time I like the cute quest bars by
my bed in case I need a snack looking
for this brush maybe it's here I just
don't understand where things go do I
misplace them is this the life that I
live I've been looking through this a
lint roller for quite some time this is
good this is great can you believe what
I just saw I am this is honestly this is
actually freaking nuts this is nuts
I found one of the pears one of the
pairs that have been missing okay this
is great we're making progress
Mady don't you even think about it Mady
don't go there I'm in shock whoa no I
felt I got excited I thought this was
some gift cards to Domino's but it's
actually just hotel keys that's quite
disappoint amazing Star Wars bag please
be in your glasses
I got this really great bag from the
Amazon I wanted it for ultra but it's it
you come in and try I can't believe I
found these hey dog gum this is a quark
sickle you freeze it and then you put it
in a bottle of wine I'm just not sure oh
you can't believe a family's this is
crazy
where do we think they are I think
they're in the case somewhere these are
my old glasses this might have been like
my first pair of glasses so precious oh
yeah I don't think so we're gonna put
those back definitely a favorite glad to
know those are still around if you guys
hadn't noticed one of the things that I
absolutely love I love sunglasses
probably a little bit too much all I
know is those sunglasses are still
missing well that's really all I've got
for you I don't really this is sort of a
nun playing video it wasn't what I
wanted to make today but you know I
I don't really know what to say
hopefully I'll resume my regularly
scheduled videos here shortly but for
now this is what you get I hope you guys
are doing well that's all I've got to
say bye and then randomly then that crow
gets up doesn't say a word walks towards
the front door